lots to look forward to then
conservative rebels are perhaps not
looking forward to today maybe the prime
minister as well a vote of confidence in
mr johnson's leadership could be
announced as early as today so far sky
news has counted 28 tory mps who've
publicly called for the prime minister
to go but many more are privately
questioning his position the chairman of
the backbench 1922 committee that's the
grand brodie is expected to count the
number of letters formally demanding a
leadership vote when he returns to
parliament
this morning
this is the formal process
here we go to trigger a leadership vote
15 percent of conservative mps as 54
have to submit no confidence letters
if that vote takes place the magic
number is 180
it would take a simple majority of
conservative mps to remove the prime
minister from office
there would then be a leadership contest
to choose a new conservative leader
tamara is at downing street for us this
morning hello to you
tomorrow
only one person knows as we always say
but but the mood music is definitely
increasing
morning k yes the rebels are
increasingly confident i put it that way
that they have met the threshold of 54
letters that is what is needed to be
sent in to call for a leadership
challenge and if they have met that
threshold we could be hearing about it
as soon as the next couple of hours we
know that over the last 10 days or so
since mps went away for their recess
after the sue gray report there has been
pressure building mps in their
constituencies hearing discontent on the
doorsteps over partygate mixed with
other concerns but the loss of trust
over partygate has been a very big
factor here and have been
publicly or privately putting in their
letters of no confidence in the prime
minister
in downing street behind me they are
braced for this happening downing street
source tells me that if it happens today
and they are braced for that outcome
then the indications are they will want
this leadership vote to be done pretty
quickly probably in the next 24 to 48
hours they they are going to fight it
every step of the way and they say that
boris johnson
is going to tell mps that he is a winner
that he has got the plan they need to
take the country forward and in fact his
chief of staff steve barkley who we had
on the programme last week has just
published an article online saying that
aimed at conservative mps saying we've
lost half of this parliament to covid it
will be our fault entirely if we choose
to waste the remaining half on
distractions over the leadership but
certainly over the weekend there was a
briefing document circulating among
conservative rebels talking about boris
johnson's unpopularity and the fact that
he was booed at the jubilee at the saint
paul's service over the weekend that
certainly chimes with what some
conservative rebels have told me that at
jubilee street parties people were
coming up to them saying it's time to
change prime minister so if it happens
moment of serious jeopardy for the prime
minister but of course if there is a
vote and he wins then he is safe from
challenge in theory for another year
i mean it was pretty staggering seeing
um i mean he did have some cheers but
there were very loud booze as well at
saint paul's on friday
when he was there with his wife um
carrie johnson but he's being referred
to also i believe tomorrow as a
conservative corbyn what does that mean
yes in this briefing document apparently
circulating amongst conservative rebels
they say that
what um what that you saw at the jubilee
is nothing that you couldn't read in the
polls that boris johnson's popularity is
really very low a lot of conservative
mps say that the polls suggest they will
lose the next election now of course the
next election is expected to be two
years away so these things do change but
they are very concerned that with him at
the helm they may be on course for
defeat and some of them clearly want to
change prime minister whether they have
the numbers to defeat him of course you
only need 54 for a challenge but once
you have a vote you need a majority of
conservative mps that will be 180 to
vote against the prime minister that is
a much higher bar and at the moment the
prime minister and his allies are
feeling very bullish about that vote the
cautionary tale the okay is if this goes
ahead that when prime ministers win
votes of confidence see theresa may
margaret thatcher john major they can be
very wounded and they don't tend to
carry on in office for that long
afterwards but at the moment the mood
here is very much that they are going to
fight this that the prime minister will
say he has a plan for the economy he's
got a speech this week on housing he's
got a plan for the health service and
that they will be very much putting
conservative mps saying this is not the
time to have a change of leader okay
thank you thanks a lot chat to you
throughout the day um health secretary
sergey javid joining us now from
kingston hospital in south west london
sorry on the steps of saint paul's on
friday um what are your reflections on
the platinum jubilee
i thought it was absolutely fantastic
and especially uh yesterday the queen uh
on the balcony and having all those
people out there to welcome
she should have rightly felt you know
very proud about that moment and uh i
think that just in the way the whole
country feels proud about our queen and
how she's served us in in such a an
amazing way for 70 years
how did you feel about the prime
minister being booed
well okay um i didn't i i saw the clips
of that uh afterwards are there were
booze they were cheers but look no no
politician is universally loved it won't
be the first time a a politician is
booed in it and uh
there will they'll be you know much of
that for many politicians down the line
i think that uh uh it's uh
you know people are perfectly entitled
to their views but what's more important
is to have a prime minister that's uh
getting on with the job that's
delivering uh for the country and and
that's exactly what we have
54 letters needed to trigger a
confidence vote in him um are you
expecting that threshold to be reached
look i i don't know
that's the honest answer no one knows at
this point apart from sir graham brady
my colleague who is the the chair of the
what's called the 1922 committee we know
that a number of colleagues have already
you know gone public with uh asking for
such a vote that's a that's a decision
of course uh for them if 54 letters are
reached i'm sure a vote will be called i
i do think it's possible but i don't
know
um i was reading in the guardian this
morning a senior mp
saying about the mood of the
constituents because of course a lot of
mps have been ashamed about in their
constituencies given the four day uh
bank holiday weekend for the platinum
jubilee saying i'm getting people coming
up to me and
greeting me with that smile and that
tilt of the head that's usually reserved
when your labrador puppy has just been
run over
goodness
look uh the the
i i i think the
this country doesn't need a vote of
confidence in the prime minister i i
think what we need to be doing as a
country is is certainly uh looking ahead
to the the challenges that exist you
know i'm here today at kingston hospital
uh standing behind this brand new
scanner by the way then i want to talk
to you about that in just a second but i
just want to deal with party gates and
then i'm going to come back to that if i
may i'll give you plenty of time to talk
about while you're in kingston but while
i while we're still talking about the
popularity of the prime minister there
was a weekend poll uh which was released
ahead of the wakefield by-election
and that's just in a couple of weeks
time it's now i don't know if you've
seen it but it makes very very very
unhappy reading for the prime minister
this morning
look i i saw that uh poll and
the there were particular circumstances
of the resignation of the former uh mp
in in wakefield and
frankly i'm not surprised by what i
saw and what i read some of the detail
around that poll but the only poll
that's going to matter is the one on the
23rd of june both for wakefield and also
tiverton and hollington you know i was
in tibetan and horton on on saturday
with helen herford our a fantastic
candidate there and certainly on the
doors that i knocked on there was uh
there was lots of support uh especially
because there was chatting to me as the
health secretary around our vaccination
program which has been world leading the
record investment that we're making
in the nhs the record increases in the
nhs workforce the the adult social care
plans came up and how we're tackling
those for the first time we have a prime
minister who's willing to tackle that so
you know they're you know let's see what
happens on the 23rd of june to fight
elections you need money uh lord michael
torres said he'll refuse to make further
donations unless boris johnson is
removed from office
look he's entitled to his view and every
political party uh has
has its donors and i am confident that i
speak to donors or potential donors to
the conservative party uh many times and
i know that many of them are fully
behind the prime minister on our program
for delivery you know that's what
motivates them what people look at
whether they're donors or
ordering people what they look at is is
is delivery we i'm standing here right
now as i say in this hospital that's
getting record investment our economy as
well we have the lowest unemployment
rate in almost uh 50 years and uh of
course we've got challenges especially
cost of living challenges the covered
backlogs but this is a government that's
getting on with the job and that's what
i think people expect politicians to
focus on a member circulating over the
weekend calling the prime minister the
conservative
corbyn
what do you make of that
well
this prime minister is the one to save
the country from corbynism if you look
back at that 2019 election there was a
very real prospect that labor under
jeremy corbyn could have won instead
this prime minister delivered the the
biggest majority that the conservatives
have seen uh since margaret thatcher's
time and and and and used that majority
to deliver for this country you're
delivering on brexit getting on with
dealing with the pandemic look did we
get every decision right the prime
minister's been very honest about this
especially when it came to the pandemic
we didn't get every decision right not
no leader in the world was able to deal
with the club pandemic and get every
decision right but we got the big
decisions right and now in the aftermath
of this pandemic
again use the health and social care
secretary i'm very focused on both of
those you're getting our health system
back up and running back to normal
dealing with those backlogs but also on
adult social care you know delivering
with a reform plan for the first time
putting in extra billions but also
leading to better integration between
health and social care that's what
people want us that's just the kind of
thing they want us to focus on
yeah but if he's so fabulous this prime
minister why is he about to face a vote
in her confidence
as i say that whether there's a vote of
uh confidence or not that's a decision
uh for my colleagues and and and you
know no no prime minister no leader of
the conservative party as far as i'm
aware of has enjoyed a hundred percent
support of uh colleagues you know where
democratic party uh we're actually the
most successful democratic party in the
western world and and and and what part
of that strength comes from having
differences of opinion at some times and
and we have processes so you know if a
if this threshold of 54 letters is
reached there will be a confidence vote
and in that case of course there should
be there may well be one if there is the
prime minister uh will will will fight
and uh
and stand his corner with a very very
strong case so let's just wait and see
what happens
uh tell me about the scanner
well this is a
as i said this is kingston hospital i'm
at today this is a brand new ct scan i
think the third one in this particular
hospital it's part of our plan to invest
billions in dealing with those uh
covered backlogs we've opened up in in
since the pandemic some 90 what we call
the community diagnostic centers these
are the new one-stop shops for
scans and tests and and checkups in the
most convenient of locations we're going
to have 160 of these in total over the
next couple of years and together they
will deliver some nine million more you
know tests and scans and checkups you're
freeing up nhs capacity this is just one
example of how we're trying to deal with
the backlog but also with the backlog
itself we're making some good progress i
think it's fair to say on dealing with
waiting times those waiting the longest
that number has been halved in in the
last four months so thanks to the the
plans that we've got but thanks most of
all to the efforts of all the staff that
are working across the nhs and i want to
take this opportunity to thank them
again for everything that they are doing
working day in day out to deliver for
patients across england
the royal college of nursing says that
um on their last shift 80 of nurses say
that staffing levels were not sufficient
to meet the needs of patients
we do need more nurses and that is why
we set out a plan at that last election
of 50 000 more nurses we've got 30 000
already just in the last year despite
the pandemic and the challenges i think
of the last year we've added 2
400 more nurses and by the way we've
also added over 4 000 doctors so we are
increasing the nhs workforce it is
challenging we need more doctors and
nurses
and we are recruiting at the highest
levels ever we've got more people
working in the nhs than ever before and
we've got more nurses in training
doctors in trading than ever before
we're pulling every lever to get the
workforce that we need okay what was
your favorite moment of the jubilee
celebrations if you don't say the queen
on the balcony paddington bear or prince
louis then you're never coming back
my favorite moment actually was
paddington bear hey i i
i i i i couldn't but i couldn't believe
it and uh nor could my kids like i
couldn't believe it but it just it just
sort of goes to show you that you know
just how amazing our queen is that she
was able to surprise us including
as i understand it her own family uh
with that very what i thought was just a
magical moment that will live with us
forever
yeah we're out of time but we just want
to show this uh to our viewers which you
shared uh on your instagram feed this
was you at the silver jubilee in 1977.
like it was yesterday eh
yeah i
i love that picture in two minds whether
i should uh tweet it out or not i showed
it to my wife and she said look get it
out there you haven't changed and uh and
i think many of us will probably have
moments like that especially if you were
lucky to be alive in 1977 and see the
silver jubilee as well and to and to
think now you know so many years on our
queen is still there and has achieved so
much more
okay great to talk to you thanks for
joining us health secretary
thank you
time now for a look at the morning's
papers with the queen's platinum jubilee
making many of the front pages the
telegraph quotes from the queen's
statement of thanks at the conclusion of
her jubilee weekend saying while i may
not have attended every event in person
my heart has been with you all the
mirror
echoes those words as well and the mail
goes with an almost identical headline
and the express two makes those words
from her majesty its top story
with a slight tweak to the spelling the
metro calls the event magical
the time says the message from the
palace balcony was the future of the
monarchy
and the sun sums it up with thank you
ma'am
still to come on the programme for you
this morning delays cues and confusion
we'll take a look at what's happening at
our airports with the independence
travel editor simon calder
going over the most memorable moments
from the queen's platinum jubilee
celebrations
with tessa dunham
just after eight joined by labour's
shadow health secretary west street
before that the defense secretary ben
wallace has announced that the uk will
give ukraine missile systems capable of
precision strikes 50 miles away
russian president vladimir putin had
warned that russia would expand its
range of targets if ukraine was supplied
with longer-range missiles
alistair standing by for us in dinipro
in central ukraine so what does all this
mean then alistair good morning
morning kay well this has been done in
coordination with the americans uh it
was at the request of the ukrainians who
believe they desperately need these new
missile systems in order to strike
russian supply lines but also long-range
russian artillery deep into
russian-held ukrainian territory
and so
after some uh deliberating over it the
white house agreed to send these systems
and then this morning the british have
announced that they will follow suit too
um the idea is it will
it won't be a game changer you know they
are precision strike they are supposed
to be very very accurate it's not
suddenly going to win the war for the
ukrainians but what they hope it will do
if they use it correctly is swinging the
momentum back in their favor
and they help push the russians back
from the positions they're in at the
moment i think they clearly have the
russians slightly rattled because over
the last week or so as rumors that these
missiles would be coming to ukraine
you've heard a few announcements from
the kremlin threatening to target areas
possibly even within europe itself if
these missile systems were sent here and
vladimir putin himself yesterday said
they would look at new targets uh to
strike if so apparently the americans
have um sought a promise from the
ukrainians that they won't be used to
hit targets inside russia itself and i
think the british will have extracted
similar guarantees but what it shows to
me is the continued level of investment
that london and washington still have in
this conflict that is grinding on and on
well there you have that vladimir putin
um interview clip that i referenced
where he was talking about the missiles
and what russia's reaction might be
actually it's worth noting that on
saturday night into the early hours of
sunday morning um some russian missiles
hit the capital key for the first time
since april so that might be an
indication
of the russian response to this move
that they start to strike elsewhere in
ukraine particularly the capital
okay for now thank you
an investigation has been launched into
the death of a man who jumped into the
river thames after being tasered by the
police
sabha is standing by for us at chelsea
bridge where the incident took place in
central london hi sabi tell us what
happened
morning kay while officers were called
here to chelsea bridge in west london on
saturday morning after receiving reports
that a man was wielding a screwdriver
and acting in a threatening manner
police then went on to taser the
individual and shortly afterwards he
jumped
off a chelsea bridge and was rescued by
the royal national lifeboat institute he
was found in a critical condition and
was shortly later taken to hospital
where he died the following day now an
independent investigation has been
called by a police watchdog and a police
body cam footage has been obtained
as a part of that
investigation now we don't yet know a
huge amount of information about this
police are yet to reveal more details
for example we don't yet know the
individual's name but what we do know
is that the man's family have been
informed
okay thank you
looking at some of today's other
headlines we know and uh disruption at
airports has continued to affect
thousands of passengers easyjet
cancelled 80 flights on sunday as the
total number of cancellations for the
weekend came close to 200. there were
also issues on eurostar and traffic
built up on the roads as the platinum
jubilee celebrations and half term came
to an end
are being advised not to use the london
underground today because of a strike by
transport workers members of the rmt
union are walking out for 24 hours in a
row over jobs and pensions some lines
will run but severe disruption is
expected across the network until 8 am
tomorrow
more than half of nurses have said that
staffing levels on their last shift were
not sufficient to meet the needs of
patients a survey by the royal college
of nursing of more than 20 000 frontline
staff suggested some are being driven
out of the job by shortages
now to what striker gareth bale has
described as the greatest results in the
history of welsh football goodness
whales are heading to their first world
cup since 1958 after a one-nil victory
over ukraine in last night's playoff in
cardiff for some fans it was simply
unbelievable
it was the year i was born and this year
we are going to the world cup
[Applause]
like certain parts of the match it was
difficult to sit and watch but oh my god
it was tense but absolutely unbelievable
i feel a bit sorry for the ukrainians
wine but
that's a game for thrones we live here
for two months and we feel so much
support here so
we decided that
in championship we will
will be fans of wales
not sure how far that's gonna get you
dan uh is standing by for us this
morning i didn't mean that dan obviously
being a little bit provocative this
monday morning uh brilliant brilliant
brilliant for wales
it was brilliant you really can't
underestimate just how electric the
atmosphere was here despite it being
incredibly soggy
last night you've got to go back to 1958
nearly 64 years since wales at last made
the world cup that was against brazil
and a young player called pele at the
age of just 17 scored the winner to
knock out wales back then that's how far
you've got to go back with the older
gentleman you saw
in those voices uh brian who we spoke to
at the gateway yesterday he actually
was at the qualifier back in 1958
and this is the first game he's been to
uh to see wales since then so he will
hopefully be going to qatar in
november good luck wales now the queen
has said she was humbled and deeply
touched by celebrations for her
platinum jubilee she thrilled thousands
of well-wishers by appearing on the
balcony of buckingham palace as the
extended bank holiday weekend came to a
close surrounded by her son her grandson
and her great grandchildren
the queen's appearance came at the
conclusion of the jubilee pageant a cast
of 6 000 performers and an array of
stars from cliff richard to basil brush
took part in the procession through
central london the parade told the story
of the queen's reign in a way that was
colourful loud sometimes eccentric but
always lots and lots of fun
in a thank you to the nation the queen
said afterwards while i may not have
attended every event in person my heart
has been with you all and i remain
committed to serving you to the best of
my ability supported by my family she
went on i've been inspired by the
kindness joy and kinship that has been
so evident in recent days and i hope
this renewed sense of togetherness will
be felt for many years to come i thank
you most sincerely for your good wishes
and for the part that you have all
played in these happy celebrations
on some of the most memorable moments of
the four day celebration were very
carefully prepared others completely
unplanned not least
that's amazing isn't it not least images
of
four-year-old louie
pulling faces on the balcony of
buckingham palace there he is
i didn't like the noise at all did it
that was for the flypast
when he was in the royal box
as my mum would say you had it on him
but he did sit on granddad's knee later
on and then all
calm was restored i bet you've got a
favorite picture haven't you of what
prince louis was up to or indeed was
there another favorite moment for you
sharing sweeties lovely that kept him
quiet for like a second uh tweet me at k
burley with your favorite moments from
the weekend so the health secretary says
it's possible a vote of confidence in
boris johnson's leadership could take
place speaking to this programme he did
say that the prime minister is focused
on getting on with the job but that if a
vote does take place he will fight his
corner i asked him whether he expected
the numbers needed for a vote to be
reached
i don't know uh that's the honest answer
no one knows at this point apart from
sir graham brady my colleague who is the
the chair of the what's called the 1922
committee we know that a number of
colleagues are already you know gone
public with uh asking for such a vote
that's a that's a decision of course uh
for them if 54 letters are reached i'm
sure a vote will be called i i do think
it's possible uh but i don't know i
think the
this country doesn't need a vote of
confidence in their prime minister uh i
think what we need to be doing as a
country is is certainly looking ahead to
the the challenges that exist no prime
minister no leader of the conservative
party as far as i'm aware of has enjoyed
a hundred percent support of uh
colleagues you know where democratic
party uh we're actually the most
successful democratic party in the
western world and and and and what part
of that strength comes from having
differences of opinion at some times and
and we have processes yeah so you know
if a if this threshold of 54 letters is
reached there will be a confidence vote
and in that case of course there should
be there may well be one if there is the
prime minister uh will will will fight
and uh and stand his corner with a very
very strong case so let's just wait and
see what happens
yes let's tomorrow's in downing street
for us um hi tamara where are you
there she is there she is hi tomorrow
yeah um goodness me it's looking
increasingly likely isn't it
very much so all the indications are
that we can expect a statement this
morning that the threshold of 54 letters
has been reached of course anything can
happen in the next hour or two mps can
withdraw their letters but all the
indications are that we are expecting a
statement this morning and therefore
there will be a leadership challenge to
the prime minister and a vote of
confidence in his leadership tory mps
vote whether they want to keep him or
whether they'd like to throw the cards
in the air and have a different leader
instead downing street officials behind
me are braced for that outcome and the
way it's been put to me by a senior
person in number 10 is if it's forced
upon us we want to dismiss it as soon as
possible boris johnson there over the
weekend at the jubilee
getting booed by members of the public i
think that has really crystallized the
issue for some conservative mps someone
i spoke to last night were saying that
at jubilee street parties they had
people coming up to them saying it's
time to change the prime minister but of
course the key question is do they have
the numbers you need 15 percent of mps
to to have the challenge but then you
need 180 to unseat the prime minister
that is a much higher bar and at the
moment you heard sajid javid there
saying the prime minister is going to
fight his corner that is very much the
attitude in the building behind me they
say this is a chance to draw a line
under it and end the speculation and
they very much hope that the prime
minister will win and therefore be safe
from challenge for another year and get
on with his agenda but of course uh
prime ministers who face leadership
challenges can be very wounded
afterwards so this is a moment of
extreme danger for boris johnson there
was a document circulating among rebels
over the weekend suggesting he'd become
the conservative corbyn all the
government's efforts had now been put
into uh trying to defend him since the
partygate allegations and then the sue
grey report came out so
really crunch time we expect for
conservative mps and a very important
day for the prime minister it's
certainly as if there was an
announcement tomorrow what would it look
like will we see sigrin brady the
chairman of the 1922 committee basically
the back bench mp shop steward will he
be in vision or uh in front of camera or
will it just percolate through to us
i would expect okay i would expect that
we would see uh graeme brady uh
somewhere in westminster giving a
statement to camera um timings uh are
fluid um but we we would expect him to
him to say something today and of course
he will have told downing street if the
threshold had been met and then he would
liaise with them about when they would
want to have the vote i remember very
well the morning that we heard that
theresa may was facing a challenge
december 2018 downing street immediately
made clear they wanted the vote that
night and so whether boris johnson's
downing street will want to have it that
quickly or whether they want to wait a
couple of days we'll have to see but
that those discussions would take place
between gray and brady and downing
street as to when the vote would happen
and then i'm sure there would be an
operation of boris johnson's allies
calling conservative mps we're already
seeing a bit of that already to say look
this is not the time to look inwardly
this is the time to get on with our
agenda we will get past this difficult
period and we'll see whether any of them
can be swayed
um social media going absolutely bonkers
the suggestions that it is going to be
this morning if it was to be this
morning is there a specific time that
serene brady would tell us or is it when
he's finished counting the number of
letters twice
um well if the threshold of letters had
been met for example last week we may
not hear about it until today there are
no published rules for conservative
leadership elections graeme brady
decides when to open the letters and
when to inform uh number ten so i if
there is um going to be an announcement
this morning and the rebels are pretty
sure that there is uh then um we would
expect he will have already made that
clear to downing street and had the
conversations already about when they
would like to have this vote of
conservative mps so it could all be
happening uh very quickly we will expect
um an announcement from him in person in
some form uh if that does happen i've
got lots more questions let me ask you
some more questions if i may um so if if
grain brady does make the announcement
will we also know at the same time
whether the prime because he'll tell the
prime minister first i'm guessing before
he tells us well we also know at the
same time whether the vote of confidence
will be this evening or will that be an
announcement that comes from downing
street
um i'm not sure whether he will announce
when the vote uh will happen i remember
that uh with with theresa may for
example um it was uh made clear shortly
so we got there was a press release
saying that there had been a leadership
challenge and then it was made clear
shortly afterwards i think by sources in
government but i if i recall correctly
that they wanted to hold the vote that
evening so he if he may say that that
has been the his the the nature of his
discussions with downing street or they
may tell us we are we're yet to find
that one out but uh certainly graham
brady must be said won't tell us how
many letters are in he won't say whether
it was 54 or 104
but we'll just know that the threshold
has been met and then really all bets
are off as to how it might go i think
what is really interesting about this 1k
is you remember at four years ago
theresa may's critics were trying to
effect a specific outcome they didn't
like her brexit deal they wanted to get
rid of her and get someone who would do
what they wanted on brexit this time
it's very different you've got
can i just interrupt you for a second
and then you can continue that thought
we're hearing according to the reuters
news agency that jesse norman
who was previously a financial secretary
to the treasury he has now also put in a
letter to graham brady to say that he
has weak faith
in the prime minister we can confirm
that i have just uh i have just seen
jesse norman's tweet to that effect and
he is interestingly kay critical of the
rwanda policy which he calls ugly likely
to be counterproductive and of doubtful
legality and that is
that really plays into what i was just
saying about these critics coming from
all sides there are people who think
that what boris johnson is doing with
the windfall tax is unconservative there
are critics from the right like andrea
ledson a leading brexiteer and then
you've got mps like jesse norman who say
what we're doing on immigration is too
hard line whereas you'll have mps in red
wall seats who will love what they're
doing on immigration but feel concerned
about partygate for example so that is
why this rebellion which has been really
building over the last 10 days or so has
been so dangerous because it has been
coming from everywhere and it will be
really difficult for boris johnson to
satisfy audit to call around and say
look i'll do this for you and i'll do
this for you these mps all want very
different things and there's really no
sense of who might win a leadership
contest these mps are throwing their
cards in the air not knowing who might
take over if boris johnson is indeed
unseated and that is why this is such a
dangerous predicament for the prime
minister at the moment okay carry on
with your thought about theresa may
because we're going to get that tweet up
for our viewers in just a second
indeed with theresa may it was um a
group of brexiteers the european
research group led by steve baker who
were trying to unseat her in order to
get rid of her brexit deal the chequers
deal and have a more hard-line version
of brexit and so she won the vote
because a lot of conservative mps didn't
want that whereas this time you've got
mps who were just disenchanted with the
leader with boris johnson himself with
his unpopularity with the fact that
they're having to go out and defend
partygate which really doesn't seem to
be going away and especially the trust
issues that stem from it so i think this
is a in a way more dangerous and you
know if it comes to a vote happening
which we do
increasingly expect at the moment i
think all bets are off as to whether the
prime minister would indeed
win that i mean they're pretty confident
behind me that there are a lot of
mps who don't want to spend the next few
months in broad and a leadership
challenge feel that there are no obvious
other contenders at downing street have
also been telling people there's no
alternative vision what do you want the
next leader to do that boris johnson
isn't doing but the concerning thing for
them is it's getting to the stage where
a lot of conservatives are just prepared
to really throw their lot in with
whoever would win uh such a contest so
um it looks increasingly like we're
going to have a very interesting morning
k um when and if that announcement is
made tomorrow let's run through this um
because pretty damning actually this
letter as i'm looking at it so perhaps
we could go through it together
absolutely he says i'm afraid i can see
no circumstances in which i could serve
in a government led by you
first as sue gray's report underlines
you have presided over a culture of
casual law breaking at 10 downing street
in relation to covid to describe
yourself as vindicated by the report is
grotesque
secondly both in the queen speech and
elsewhere your current policy priorities
are deeply questionable breach of the
northern ireland protocol would be
economically very damaging politically
foolhardy and almost certainly illegal
oh goodness me goes on to talk about
rwanda the policy in rwanda is ugly um
genuinely conservative no genuinely
conservative government should have
supported the recent ban on noisy
protest least of all when basic human
freedoms are facing the threat of
extinction in ukraine on it goes
i mean i've covered politics for 10
years okay i don't think i've ever read
anything quite like this i mean this is
really excoriating from you know former
treasury minister jesse norman saying
that he cannot support the prime
minister on pretty much every single
count but of course most damningly on
his personal integrity and you know it
really speaks for himself obviously we
don't know how many other mps share his
views but certainly it really does show
what a mountain the prime minister would
have to climb to try and talk down some
of these people who want to vote against
him as leader you've got mps who can't
stand the the rwanda policy you've got
mps who um who have got concerns about
the direction he's going in on the
economy and that you know this this is
why it's going to be so difficult to
dampen down such a rebellion must be
said the view in the building behind me
is if they even win
by a small amount remember theresa may
got two-thirds of mps voting for her in
the in the no confidence vote in the end
but she was gone six months later so in
the building behind me they are
concentrating on just winning such a
vote but of course once uh even if boris
johnson were to win were to get enough
support you've got critics like this
having made these statements saying they
don't like the you know the what what's
referred to as the culture war these
dividing lines and that is really going
to make it very difficult for him to to
carry on even if he does win the vote
okay so um how where are we on the
numbers tomorrow
so we need 54. that's 15 percent of
conservative mps uh to for the
leadership challenge the rebels are very
confident that they have met that
threshold or indeed exceeded it um and
and then you'd need 180 a majority uh to
unseat the prime minister we've been
doing a spreadsheet of who's put in a
letter and um those mps who have said
the prime minister should resign are
around 28 but those who have made
criticisms of boris johnson which sound
pretty damning are at over 40 but those
numbers
only tell us part of the story because i
know of conservative mps who have put
letters in who have never said anything
have never published a statement on
their website and there are some on that
list who have been critical but not
actually put a letter in so what is
really important is how many letters
have gone into gray and brady which are
secret which he reads secretly and it's
important to say that the no confidence
vote is also a secret ballot so you may
get members of the cabinet going on
television supporting the prime minister
who will then go and secretly vote
against him in the leadership vote that
is why it is so dangerous it's just been
pointed out to me kay and i wanted to
mention that you know the prime minister
goes on a lot about the vaccine rollout
well kate bingham who of course led the
vaccine task force is the wife of jesse
norman the treasury minister so uh that
gives an interesting perspective on it
uh it certainly does now the ball
started rolling probably one of the most
high profile people tomorrow would have
been oh i don't know would we say maybe
tobias elwood
tobias elwood has certainly been one of
the prime minister's most vocal critics
and has been calling for him to go um
for for some time now um he has um you
know said to us in the last few days
that the support he was getting behind
the scenes you know he was a lone voice
for a long time saying the prime
minister should go that his integrity
was putting the whole conservative
party's project at risk he was saying to
us that he was getting quite a lot of
support behind the scenes from even from
ministers
and it sounds like that may be borne out
or we'll see how it bears out in the
next couple of hours if this vote is is
called and of course what the result is
but um certainly he has been one of
those who who put his head above the
parapet when others didn't want to and
it would be interesting to see how much
opinion has crystallized
over the weekend because you know i've
spoken to tory mps we're at jubilee
street parties with die-hard
conservative members with union jack
cakes they baked saying it's time to
change prime minister that is something
that will
send shivers down the spine of
conservatives in marginal seats and not
so marginal ones and so
that that is where we are and sajid
javid the health secretary uh was pretty
resigned i thought to a challenge
happening he just said that the prime
minister would try to fight it this is
what the health secretary told us in the
last hour
i thought it was absolutely fantastic
and especially
yesterday the queen
on the balcony and having all those
people out there to welcome she should
have rightly felt you know very proud
about that moment and uh i think that
just in the way the whole country feels
proud about our queen and how she served
us in in such a an amazing way for 70
years
how did you feel about the prime
minister being booed
well okay um i didn't i i saw the clips
of that uh afterwards there were booze
there were cheers but look no no
politician is universally loved it won't
be the first time a a politician is
booed in it and uh
there will be there'll be you know much
of that from many politicians down the
line i think that uh
it's uh
you know people are perfectly entitled
to their views but what's more important
is to have a prime minister that's uh
getting on with the job that's
delivering uh for the country and and
that's exactly what we have
54 letters needed to trigger a
confidence vote in him um are you
expecting that threshold to be reached
look i i don't know
that's the honest answer no one knows at
this point apart from sir graham brady
my colleague who is the the chair of the
what's called 1922 committee we know
that a number of colleagues have already
you know gone public with uh asking for
such a vote that's a that's a decision
of course uh for them if 54 letters are
reached i'm sure a vote will be called i
i do think it's possible uh but i don't
know
um i was reading in the guardian this
morning a senior mp
saying uh about the mood of the
constituents because of course a lot of
mps have been ashamed about in their
constituencies given the four day bank
holiday weekend for the platinum jubilee
saying i'm getting people coming up to
me and
greeting me with that smile and that
tilt of the head that's usually reserved
when your labrador puppy has just been
run over
goodness
look at the the i i i i think the
this country doesn't need a vote of
confidence in the prime minister i i
think what we need to be doing as a
country is is certainly uh looking ahead
to the the challenges that exist you
know i'm here today at kingston hospital
uh standing behind this brand new
scanner by the way there i want to talk
to you about that in just a second but i
just want to deal with party gates and
then i'm going to come back to that if i
may i'll give you plenty of time to talk
about while you're in kingston but while
i while we're still talking about the
popularity of the prime minister there
was a weekend poll uh which was released
ahead of the wakefield by-election um
and that's just in a couple of weeks
time isn't it i don't know if you've
seen it but it makes very very very
unhappy reading for the prime minister
this morning
look i i saw that uh poll and uh
the there were particular circumstances
the resignation of the former uh mp in
wakefield and
frankly i'm not surprised by what i
saw and what i read some of the detail
around that poll but the the only poll
that's going to matter is the one on the
23rd of june both for wakefield and also
tiverton and hollington you know i was
in tibetan and horton on on saturday
with helen herford our fantastic
candidate there and certainly on the
doors that i knocked on there was there
was lots of support uh especially
because there was chatting to me as the
health secretary around our vaccination
program which has been world leading the
record investment that we're making
in the nhs the record increases in the
nhs workforce the the adult social care
plans came up and how we're tackling
those for the first time we have a prime
minister who's willing to tackle that so
you know they're they're you know let's
see what happens on the 23rd of june to
fight elections you need money uh lord
michael torres said he'll refuse to make
further donations unless boris johnson
is removed from office
look he's entitled to his view and every
political party uh has has has its
donors and
i am confident that i speak to donors or
potential donors to the conservative
party uh many times and i i know that
many of them are fully behind the prime
minister and our program for delivery
you know that's what motivates them what
people look at whether they're donors or
uh ordering people what they look at is
is is delivery we i'm standing here
right now as i say in this hospital
that's getting record investment our
economy as well we have the lowest
unemployment rate in almost uh 50 years
and uh of course we've got challenges
especially cost of living challenges the
covered backlogs but this is a
government that's getting on with the
job and that's what i think people
expect politicians to focus on a member
of circulating over the weekend calling
the prime minister the conservative
corbyn
what do you make of that
well
this prime minister is the one to save
the country from corbynism if you look
back at that 2019 election there was a
very real prospect that labor under
jeremy corbyn could have won instead
this prime minister delivered the the
biggest majority that the conservatives
have seen uh since margaret thatcher's
time and and and and used that majority
to deliver for this country you're
delivering on brexit getting on with
dealing with the pandemic look did we
get every decision right the prime
minister's been very honest about this
especially when it came to the pandemic
we didn't get every decision right not
air no leader in the world was able to
deal with the global pandemic and get
every decision right but we got the big
decisions right and now in the aftermath
of this pandemic
again it was a health and social care
secretary i'm very focused on both of
those you're getting our health system
back up and running back to normal
dealing with those backlogs but also on
adult social care you know delivering
with a reform plan for the first time
putting in extra billions but also
leading to better integration between
health and social care that's what
people want us that's just the kind of
thing they want us to focus on
yeah but it'd be so fun
here in downing street the prime
minister is braced for an imminent
challenge to his leadership rebel
conservative mps are increasingly
confident that they're they have met the
threshold of 54 to trigger a vote of
confidence in the prime minister and we
are expecting that an announcement could
be made as soon as the next couple of
hours with downing street telling me
that if it is forced upon them they will
want to dismiss it as soon as possible
by holding that vote as quickly as they
can of course half of conservative mps
that's 180 would have to vote against
the prime minister in order to unseat
him but we are now seeing rebels coming
from all directions in the party with
the latest
former minister jesse norman saying that
the prime minister's behaviour around
partygate had been grotesque this is a
moment of immense danger for the prime
minister as he faces challenges from all
sides and could be out of a job if that
that vote of confidence in his
leadership succeeds in ousting him booed
of course and paul's cathedral over the
weekend does that reflect more
widespread opinion in the conservative
party we will find that out pretty soon
it looks like with an announcement
expected as soon as this morning by
graham brady the chair of conservative
back benches expected as soon as this
morning
[Music]